former runner-up Nick Viall came back
last night now you'll recall he's the
guy who actually put Angela blast for
having sex with him so many are now
calling this the most messed up
bachelorette season ever he is gonna be
moving in tonight the end of the day
it's just a decision that I have to
explore the men shocked and dismayed the
tension out of control in next week's
promo guys I'll never trust you you
don't need to trust me I don't he just
blatantly lied to us when we kissed on
the pier I was like okay this is
undeniable wasn't terrible before the
show started Caitlin only had a
friendship with Nick over email and text
she talked to me about his surprise
appearance showing up conveniently after
a group day you were happy to see that
Nick came back yeah I was yeah it was a
friendship in my mind I hadn't even
thought about a relationship so when I
saw him and that he booked a one-way
ticket and left his job and he was there
for me I'm gonna explore that I'm not
here to be the villain and cue the
makeout but Andy Dorfman's tweet summed
up what many of you and our et community
seem to think about this situation one
word run okay to run fast is this guy
just chasing the limelight and as if
that weren't messed up enough well last
night we experienced an epic breakup
between the brokeback bromance bachelors
JJ and Clint after Clint was basically
kicked out of the house that's so what
so your darling I'm done I don't press
you this is insane that gave + ej j a
chance to throw his bestie under the bus
I think why I say sorry it's all a
monster I need to apologize bring on the
bro guilt I'm sorry for Jonah don't
touch me okay not augur shut up there
cuz I'm gonna kill you